sommes-nous de plus en plus pauvres au
québec
c'est la question que pose cette année
les organisateurs de la grande guignolée
des médias
un événement qui en est à sa quinzième
édition les chiffres les plus récents
leur donne raison
c'est exact de plus en plus de montréal
est dépendant des banques alimentaires
les gens aujourd'hui enfin qu'on ne 146
mille personnes à montréal qui ont
recours et de l'aide alimentaire et que
si on n'existe plus demain matin ses 146
mille personnes là dont environ 34 mille
enfants ne mangeaient pas à leur faim
parmi les raisons qui expliquent ce
problème le prix de la nourriture qui
augmente en flèche soit plus rapidement
que les revenus des gens en difficulté
ce qui m'effraie c'est que 37% des
salariés au québec travail d'un chèque à
l'eau dont aucune possibilité de mettre
des fonds pour un fonds d'urgence ou
même planifier sa retraite
alain gingras guimond a eu recours à
l'aide alimentaire il y à une quinzaine
d'années nous les familles des mineurs
elle nous permettait de mettre de
glisser quelques à gâteau cadeau à tous
des sapins donc j'imagine c'est la
réalité de beaucoup de monde ex pour ça
que c'est important de donner à noël de
donner à la guignolée à toutes les
guinéennes et qu'il y en a d'autres
ses deux filles tout jeune à l'époque se
souviennent encore de cette période de
leur vie
j'ai des beaux souvenirs le des paniers
je savais pas d'où ça venait moi c'est
un gros panier avec la nourriture qu'on
avait jamais eu
puis ça me rendait vraiment heureuse je
découvrais plein de nouvelles affaires
toute l'aide alimentaire ça aide les
parents à avoir une assurance à être
moins stressé à la maison comme on
faisait en fait ne jamais 37 pauvres
parce qu'il s'adonnait peut-être plus de
la force de mon père cette sécurité le
sur le terrain
la grande guignolée des médias débute
demain à 6 heures du matin se termine à
18 heures et plus de 500 bénévoles
participe à la récolte des dons de mélo
demain matin quand ça va être le temps
de donner à la grande gueule des médias
c'est de dire penser à ces gens là qui
serait là dans le temps de noël devant
l'assiette vide c'est normal grondin
radio-canada mourir